the best thing that someone can do who
wants to keep government accountable in
the in their city is to shine a light on
the truth Kelly Thomas was a
schizophrenic homeless man spent a lot
of time in Fuller's in was known to
business owners residents the police for
many many years he was hanging out in
the Fulton transportation center the
police were going to arrest him and
instead they beat him and taste him to
death so we've got this blog and
basically we cover local issues and we
talk about politics and freedom and
things like that it does have a small
government angle to it private property
rights civil liberties a lot of times we
just focus on really the practical
issues this was something new this was
something way beyond what we've seen
before in terms of abuse and I've heard
stories like this but we've never had
something so covered in depth and
something where where we've had so many
people witness such a horrific crime
that they were willing to come forward
and talk and tell us what happened you
know usually these things get kind of
covered up and shovel shovel under the
rug there are just so many components of
this that caused it to blow up the
primary one being Kelly's dad Ron having
the presence of mind to take photos of
his son in the hospital in that state
not even cleaned up we were the first to
get the photo of Kelly in the hospital
beat up the picture was so horrific that
the local news channels wouldn't show it
and you know a lot of times they just
don't think there's much of a story
there because they get the police
version of the story which is there was
a guy who's in a fight and now he's dead
police say they received a call someone
breaking into cars
officers allege they talked with Thomas
but when they tried to arrest him Thomas
at 5 foot 10 165 pounds fought back for
several minutes we've been complaining
about the decline of local media for a
long time and and this is just a perfect
example of that where they've lost so
much incentive to actually spend time
digging into stories and covering things
that the community basically misses out
on knowing what's really happening and
so we took it upon ourselves to dig up
all this information and just pass along
the truth to people and that's you know
that's what happened and then the
newspapers and the reporters came later
this next story started out with a video
posted on YouTube I have to warn you the
picture I'm about to show you is very
graphic because we were the first to
post this things and we were the ones
who who were talking about it the most
all these sites all over the Internet
have linked to us you know we've been
mentioned in news reports and we've been
interviewed in news reports and there
were probably at least six officers
there trying to do mr. Thomas having
great difficulty and so doing him while
they were trying to take him into
custody so there's a police public
information officer named Andrew
Goodrich who is responsible for
disseminating information to the public
and what we've learned in the past is
that he is not conducive to open
communication in the public and he'll
pass along whatever the police want us
to know and he'll omit everything else
so it's really difficult to get to the
truth when you're when you're digging
into into police matters and you know
there's a lot of they have a lot of
rights they have the ability to cover
things up and conceal things from the
public and and so you know basically
they can Stonewall us and that's what he
did and you know his he also has a
position pretty high up in the in the
police officers union and so that gives
them a lot of political advantage being
able to control the information that
comes out of a police department and
that's what happened here I think Andrew
Goodrich is a union hack you know I
think that there is clearly collusion
between the city the city leadership the
police force management which is not
Union and the union leadership to
portray the police in the best most
professional life possible what I find
most amazing about watching that
is that these folks actually believe
they're doing the right thing that they
actually believe that if something goes
wrong that what best serves the
community is to sweep that the truth
under the rug and just characterize the
circumstances in the most palatable way
possible they will not say if they tased
him since it's under investigation and
so far cannot comment on whether
excessive force was used we're gonna
conduct a thorough investigation and if
there were any actions that weren't
justified then then that will come out
in that investigation well when it gets
this bad when the situation is this ugly
they lose sight of the fact that they
need to say wow folks this is really bad
and we realize it and there may be some
facts that we don't know yet but boy are
we committed to getting all of that out
to you as quick as possible and if
anybody committed murder they're going
down and it may don't get that they
don't get that they need to scratch that
itch the other side of this is local
media and newspapers are hopelessly
dependent on police departments for
regular everyday news coming from the
police blotter I've had several of them
tell me matter-of-factly that I can't
run a story critical of the police
department because I have to go in there
every day and get the get the stuff from
the police information the public
information officer of the police
department I'm charging officer Manuel
Ramos with second-degree murder one
felony count of second-degree murder and
I'm also charging officer Ramos with one
felony count of involuntary manslaughter
if convicted he faces a maximum sentence
of 15 years to life in state prison
corporal Jason le is charged with one
felony count of involuntary manslaughter
and one felony count of the use of
excessive force they've convicted he
faces a maximum sentence of four years
in state prison I think the DA told a
very riveting story in in his
progression of the circumstances of the
case and really gave everybody the long
drink of water that they needed and
finally hearing the specifics of
you know what happened what was said the
showing of intent by Ramos Ramos leaned
over Kelly Thomas in this in his most
menacing way he made two fists with his
gloves on two fists
he lifted his fists to Kelly Thomas in
front of the stage so that he could see
them and he said now seem like this
they're getting ready to f you up it was
it was more than most of us expected
that there was a murder charge his first
murder charge of a police officer in the
course of duty in Orange County history
and so we didn't expect him over charge
we knew he there should be one but we
didn't expect it so you know we wish it
would have gone further but it went way
further than I anticipated so there was
some gratification there Ron was pleased
Ron Thomas the transparency is key to a
solid government that protects people's
rights and to avoid tyranny really is
secrets are that are the first thing I
government we use when they want to put
their foot down on people is they'll
keep keeping secrets the best thing that
someone can do who wants to keep
government accountable in the in their
city is to shine a light on the truth
and and basically communicate to as many
people as you can
what's really happening and you've got
to find compelling stories and you got a
you got to hook people in with with the
truth but people want the truth people
will will seek it out and you know and
that's really the best thing you can do
you